he says it's good all right let's get
started thanks for coming out you most
of you probably know me I'm Aaron Cohen
I'm associate professor in the
department of clinical informatics and
medical informatics and clinical
epidemiology and this is an informatics
discovery lab leadership talk hosted by
the department and I'm very pleased
today to a host dr. Daniel Slater was a
candidate for a faculty position and
Department Daniel holds a PhD in civil
engineering from the University of
Washington and has received an MBI in
clinical informatics from ohsu in 2012
he's currently a senior systems
application analyst with the ohsu su
pharmacy informatics group is interests
or data integration and analysis systems
design and use of informatics to provide
more efficient say for an effective
patient care is recent projects include
participating in the epic willow
ambulatory implementation here at ohsu
enabling research access to pathology
data and automating supply chain data
processes this talk will explore how
systems integration furthers the Triple
Aim of improving health care and cost
and satisfaction by enabling operations
oriented research now I'm supposed to
say number one that Dan is happy to stay
after his talk to talk to the fellows I
guess there was some sort of snafu with
the room in the hour before so if you
guys want to hang out afterwards he's
available to that I'm also supposed to
say that though we're recording these
presentations so anybody who hasn't hear
it been here before when you have
questions press and hold the touch
button while you ask your questions so
that there are recorded and our we live
streaming and tweeting today brought and
we are live streaming and tweeting today
so if anybody listening on the live
stream has a question they can tweet to
our twitter address which is brett at
ohsu informatics until they need a
hashtag hashtag demise comets Saudi mais
conf right okay and with that I will
give it over to Dan thank you I was
asked earlier today how I came to
medical informatics and I have to say
it's just that I asked Google and Google
told me to do it I I don't know if I'd
recommend that for everybody but I I was
trying to figure out a way to to put
together some software and engineering
and research and public health
experience so i just typed those words
into google and it kept telling me
medical informatics so my next question
was well what's that and so two years
later i had the opportunity to graduate
from the NBI program here and i've been
working at pharmacy services ever since
we're lucky to have Joe Fazio the
assistant director for pharmacy services
here with us who I met also at the
informatics program so thank you for
this opportunity to talk
first I just like to talk about what
pharmacy services where where I fit in
here we sit under Jonas vice-president
percept professional services our
director is in fam and Joe is the
assistant director of business services
and working for him is Neela Dillo my
manager who's the manager of the
informatics group which currently has
approximately 17 or 18 people in it
roughly six pharmacists informatica
informatics pharmacists approximately
four or five application analysts and
then support analyst computer support
analysts and and trainers
so
I was originally hired to help with epic
implementation for the willow ambulatory
module that was replacing our old
pharmacy informatics system information
system so a lot of the work that we've
been doing is putting new systems in
place our goal I've was last August and
we're working hard on emerging from that
phase and moving into a maintenance
phase right now which we're getting
pretty close to doing in the process of
putting these systems together it
occurred to me that we really are
furthering the Triple Aim of health care
which is to simultaneously increase the
experience of care reduce costs and
increase population health this is the
framework that ihi uses and I've circled
the red the red frames are around areas
that I think I'm touching on today all
of these everything from defining what
quality is system level metrics the
individual patients and their families
who come up to outpatient pharmacy to
get their drugs the integration of
systems to help deliver the product to
them and how that is ultimately going to
make this a more efficient and
cost-effective process
no I'm I hope nobody plays any game that
involves counting how many times I used
the word system today okay but let's
just start off with what's the
definition I mean merriam-webster gives
a fairly straightforward definition i
prefer the definition that was taught to
me by one of the founding members of n
coasts who said basically a system is
defined by a boundary if you can't draw
a boundary around it you don't have a
system I think he was talking to
specifically around about closed systems
just to be clear
so from a analytics perspective how does
the Triple Aim come into this project
because ultimately we need to use
analytics to to understand how we how we
measure things and how we try to improve
things so I've highlighted the
objectives that I think come into play
in this project analytics for improving
customer satisfaction acquisition and
retention we want to we want to have
patience happy with the service they
receive and come back to the pharmacy
for drugs we want to reduce costs and
increase our efficiency we want to
increase revenue and return on
investment at the pharmacy because it is
a business concern and we want to
optimize our supply chain and human
capital management so we don't want
inventory to grow too large it costs too
much we want to get drugs when we need
it
so this is taken from an IBM white paper
and the last graphic was two of the
value of analytics in healthcare and
this is the result of a series of
interviews they did with executives and
in the health care industry and other
industries the top demand the top data
priority in healthcare is integration of
disparate sources it's going to be a
consistent theme that's going to show up
in this talk you know other other
important items here are standardization
how confident are you in the data that
you get out of your systems healthcare
data is is dirtier than a lot of people
understand how timely can we get the
data in and can we reduce the complexity
of the data so that we can use it and of
course security of the data we get we
get orders from all kinds of different
places we get orders from the web we get
people calling in web is my chart which
is also integrated with epic we have an
IVR into integrated voice response
system so that's the automated message
system you call in with a refill
punching your numbers and then the order
gets routed into pharmacy you have
external eat prescriptions from external
prescribers and we have a system that
connects them electronically to our
system we have discharged patients that
discharge orders are signed from the
hospital and they appear in outpatient
pharmacy and we have ambulatory clinics
infusion clinics where patients visit
outside and they have to be served also
now there's this this is a little bit of
a misleading graphic because there's
this huge block in the middle that says
pharmacy what does that mean that is
representation of our implementation in
August we have a huge block of orders in
the system that we already had
that we don't know where they came from
but they were already in the pharmacy
system and they had to be transferred
into the new pharmacy system so that
gives you an idea of the relative size
of legacy orders and new orders this
data set covers the data set i'm talking
about will cover october 2012 through
februari octo I'm sorry oktober 2013
through february2014 all right so that's
that's the time frame we're looking at
so I just like to take a walk through a
number of the systems that that the
pharmacy uses to connect to the outside
world and this is really kind of will
give you an idea of the complexity of
the project that we had to undertake
when during our implementation just
feeding orders into epic the shaded
areas the light shaded areas and I'm
sorry the color doesn't show up as well
here as as on screen but the light
shading is existing and the darker
shading is new systems that we had to
modify or implement so we have on the
left all the source of information eep
ascribing from epic the ivr the external
prescribing telephone fax and written
walk in all of these interfaces needed
to be reworked and of course the willow
ambulatory module was a new interface
itself so now we have systems for
getting the drugs out of our information
system in to the patients so again we
have epic as the source and we have an
interface between every endpoint there's
an interface between the dispensing
robot which about half of the larger
operations volume gets dispensed through
very important interface the most
important interface is probably with the
insurance switch this is how we find out
if patients can pay for the drugs
insurance covers it real time we have a
separate print server that's just for
pharmacy printing separate interfaces
for the sales till and the will-call
storage cabinet and we also have a drug
information database that supplies
medication monographs and images
descriptions of drugs that get printed
out along with the prescription labels
will call storage cabinet is they have
some automated storage cabinets where
when the prescription is ready for
pickup it gets stored securely when a
patient finally walks up it might be the
next day it might be a week later the
prescription is removed from the storage
cabinet and it's out story we also have
to order drugs from our supplier how do
we do that we have another set of
systems for that the user creates a file
that gets deposited on Epix native
server then it gets transferred by an
information technology utility to a
windows location where the end users can
access it and then it gets uploaded to
the website so that entire system is new
that didn't exist before
and we also have a system for tracking
drug purchases and this is all new so
this is a lot of the work that I was
doing over the implementation period it
turns out that there's something called
a 340b drug program I don't know if any
of you have heard of it but it's a
pricing program that allows hospitals
like ours to serve indigents who can't
pay for drugs and allows you to buy back
drugs at tremendous discounts for
manufacturers but you have to track
which prescriptions are eligible to be
replaced at this low price and which
aren't this is worth millions of dollars
to the to the pharmacy and if you get it
wrong and you're out of compliance you
can be yanked from the program and lose
all that so it's pretty important for
pharmacy to get that right so
it looks fairly complicated but the
reason I'm showing this is that
ultimately this is an example of how
sometimes you have to take multiple
considerations into account when you
design a system any write a program in
this case we have a situation where epic
had a delay in supplying their 340b
tracking software and they couldn't
deliver it in time for our goal I this
is a huge record-keeping problem for
pharmacy pharmacy processes
approximately 1,500 prescriptions per
day and I devised the system that allows
us to track the difference between what
we buy than what we sell and determine
which prescriptions are eligible for the
program the buying program and I put
that in place as a stopgap measure until
that can come up with their module okay
so this part here this accumulator is
what we call it the tracking software
this part here in this part here I wrote
this has a lifetime this part has a
lifetime design lifetime of only about
four months it's designed to be just
meet the minimum requirements that we
have and then be thrown away and
replaced with commercial software
because a team of people working for
years on a product is going to put a
superior product in place to anything I
can do in 500 hours there's just no way
around it
but it's functioning as a stopgap
measure right now kind of works works
well enough for our purposes I'm very
eager to have them put the commercial
product in place so I don't have to
support this anymore so but there's a
separate part going on here this is all
these are invoices from our drug
supplier how are we going to know what
we purchased the existing system
involves people when they get the time
going up to a website and manually
downloading invoices putting them into a
spreadsheet and trying to do analysis on
that it's very time-consuming and it
doesn't always happen you know if people
have real jobs they've got lots of other
demands on their time so it's a
challenge for people to do that
consistently so the system that gets set
up here is a daily feed from the drug
supplier that's the top where it says x
12 invoice this is a coded format it
gets transferred through an itg system
through a secure server from the
external supplier to our internal system
where there's this this component this
parser uses it to keep track of
purchases against the dispenses and keep
a balance of what we're eligible to buy
back for 340b but there's another value
here because pharmacy has a different
name they need to keep a running record
of their purchases they have to be able
to analyze what they buy in order to
keep their costs down and to know
whether purchasing is if there's a
problem or not so this part here this
purchasing record is a separate file
that has a completely different value
than what the accumulator has that has a
different design lifetime so that's
probably going to be about one to two
years lifetime
because we're trying to integrate that
information into our enterprise system
at that point we can probably do away
with my home made my homemade parser so
you have a system that has multiple
parts each part has a different lifetime
and it's all designed to ultimately be
replaced by something else every system
has a finite lifetime
so just a couple of these ideas for
designing systems for change involve
decoupling things have to be able to
work in independent parts standardized
interfaces so that if you take out one
part you can plug in another one and you
know it's going to work standardized
content you have to look at multiple
stakeholders needs in the case of our
previous system in the case of the
previous system we had a billing system
to get invoice data into our billing
department but it was the billing people
all they needed was the total amount of
each invoice they didn't understand that
pharmacy is a separate need for knowing
what is in the invoice what are you
buying what kind of drugs are you buying
and that's what that purchasing record
replaced it took an existing system that
one stakeholders need with a system that
meets multiple stakeholders things and
now more stakeholders within pharmacy
are starting to call and say what about
that file you're keeping can I have
access to that and that's what
ultimately is going to prove the value
of anything that you put in place is if
people start coming around and asking
for
so I'm not done with systems yet right
so there's like a whole bunch of these
small systems that feed into larger
systems and still into now systems that
report information out to end users so
that they can use it we have this this
is from the clinical informatics
reporting team I've copied their slide
thank you very much this is sort of the
reporting system that's in place right
now at ohsu you have some reporting
workbench straight out of epics backend
that's cachet you have a daily extract
transform and load into clarity which is
the relational database system that sits
outside you have the data warehouse that
has a separate extract transform and
load system and various reporting tools
that come from these different sources
that people use
why do I care about this we have built
if I don't care about this we've only
built the silo in terms of that
purchasing data we have to figure out a
way to get financial data and purchasing
data from pharmacy streams separate
pharmacy streams on the left into the
ohsu data warehouse so that we can
combine that information with the
overall enterprise then use it you know
in an integrated fashion so that's a
current project that we're working on
that's I don't know that might take a
year to two years to complete that
that's why I said the purchasing report
has maybe a one to two-year life cycle
then I'll be put away and an enterprise
system will come in place now a friend
of mine at itg jokes with me and says I
tell them I don't I don't write
enterprise software he says well they're
using it so now you do so but that just
scares me so I try not to think of it
that way so I just want to take a take a
break from all this systems talk there's
a lot that's a lot of information about
many different systems but it gives you
an idea of you know the complexity of
the healthcare enterprise and how things
have to fit together in different
considerations so you've all seen the
MGM our adoption model so I just want to
take a break take a look at this where
are we where are we I think I think you
know we have closed loop medication
administration impatient that's stage 5
we have some structured templates that
we're putting in place through pharmacy
and there may be some in other areas i'm
not familiar with them i'd say we're
probably at least stage 6 it's my guess
I don't know if other people think
differently
but there's a difference between having
systems in place and actually using them
to do so I mean besides patient care but
I mean what are you going to use the
four so back from this white paper that
IBM put out and this is from joint a
joint study with MIT sloan management
review i think this is a really good
graphic that kind of talks about not the
systems but what you do with the
information that comes out of the
systems because that's the next step
really otherwise we're just building
computer programs so the way they they
divided up is aspirational experienced
and transformed and I'd like to kind of
frame the rest of the talk in terms of
these different stages of how we use
analytics so my interpretation of what
that graphic says is that aspiration
aspirational use you want to use it but
the lack of systems integration makes
using it too cost-prohibitive it's very
it's difficult to use the systems you
have so we want to do it we aspire to do
it so just for an example I'll present
some data comparing turnaround time to
two different operations all right and
this is from before we put the new
system in place it was very difficult to
combine the data in a way that we could
efficiently make use of it
we have different operations with
different workflows there are a lot of
different definitions of turnaround time
there's lots but if you want to compare
across different systems how are you
going to do that are you going to have
to use different metrics or can you come
up with a metric that lets you compare
two different systems we have at the top
we have outpatient pharmacy the first
two steps are the same as central fill
pharmacy patient calls in for a refill
in the pharmacy it gets filled and
verified but for central fill they ship
it out one time per day 3 p.m. for
outpatient pharmacy they put it in the
will-call cabinet and knows when the
patient's going to show up how do you
know you know what's the actual
difference between getting it to the
patient from the time it comes in well
come up with your own metric that
reflects that let's say take the number
of business days to ship from central
fill the number of business days to will
call and sales in a number of business
days to the will call system so that's
actually the the time that the central
pharmacy outpatient pharmacy puts the
drug in will call and it's available
which is the real endpoint because the
patient could come up anytime if you
wait for the sales till to ring that's
not an accurate representation of that
turnaround time don't include weekends
for one operation they don't work on the
weekends so you have to put together a
bunch of different systems you have to
put together data from this voice
response system that's not connected to
your pharmacy information system and
then we'll call system which is separate
and then join them up together and you
can calculate your turnaround times that
takes a lot of effort that's not really
a tenable way to produce analytics on a
on a regular basis takes too much time
but just for example we did it and turns
out that can tell you some interesting
things in this example I broke it down
by what day does the customer call the
order in does that make a difference in
terms of how long takes for the patient
to get their drug well kind of does
the Blue is for mailing out shipping out
most of the orders come in the refill
orders come in over the weekend there's
a lot so on Monday there's your peak
turnaround time the people who call in
on Saturday have the lowest Turner I
this is business days so in reality if
somebody calls in on saturday the clock
doesn't start ticking until monday
monday is zero the first day tuesday
about tuesday the order gets shipped out
if you call in on saturday if you call
in on monday your order get shipped out
sometime around friday that's not too
bad but look look what happens you still
have like a four day calendar time
difference so that's fairly consistent
but look what happens if you call in for
shipping
for pickup deliver things if you call in
an order to get delivered to your
pharmacy on campus from central Phil on
Thursday
you're waiting until next week but if
you call in your order to get it
delivered on Friday it's probably going
to show up the next day that's
interesting
so we give this we give this information
operations so they can go over it and it
changes change their staffing if they
have to look at the way they process
their orders it's actionable information
that they can use to improve their
operations if we look at the other
outpatient operation wow look at that
everything pretty much goes out the same
day these are people who are getting
discharged from the hospital they come
by to pick up their meds they know they
call in their orders some walkins people
just walk up with scripts in their hand
so this operation tends to get things
out same day this here sometimes they
put together in order and they ship it
out to central fill for mailing out to
places that's an anomaly that seven is
an anomaly there are four particular
orders that had special circumstances
around them so that's a small data set
that's not really you know it's an
outlier I would say but you can use this
metric to to compare different
operations ivr into two will call
coupling and look at how things very how
you might want to adjust your operations
if you want to smooth things out make
changes but it takes a lot of time this
took this this analysis took a week at
least to figure out how to get the
different systems together join up the
data do something that was that was
actionable it's just not possible to do
that on a regular basis if you've got an
implementation going on
so I would say that's kind of an
aspirational stage of analytics we want
to use the data it's hard to get to we
can't really use it on a regular basis
so what about the nest next stage the
experience stage of using analytics so
let's use these systems that we put in
place let's use the integration to
produce data information not data
information we're working on putting
dashboards in place but they're not
fully implemented yet that's sort of
this current stage of the process that
we're in we're still implementing the
full capability of the integration so I
mean I would say that I think that we're
emerging from the aspirational stage and
trying to enter the experience stage
right now that's that's where pharmacy
is that and we'll get there
oops
so you know I took the opportunity to
this this talk to give myself a little
kick in the pants do some data mining
and start looking for some patterns
sometimes we can't give a complete drug
Phil to patients because there isn't
enough stock we call that a partial fill
I was thinking well if we have the
highest volume days you would expect
that there would be more partial fills
because you might not be as ready for
the demand that doesn't really show it
this is a pretty weak relationship this
isn't this is a pretty weak relationship
I have to keep looking questions are why
is there why is there no relationship or
little well it turns out that there's
other information that suggests that
inventory is growing too much at
pharmacy which would help explain why
there doesn't seem to be much of a
correlation between how much volume you
have and what percent of your orders are
partial fills possible it's just a
suggestion but it provides a background
of what's going on I'm trying to
understand right now also why there
seems to be a higher rate of
prescriptions that get cancelled after
they are filled and waiting for patient
pick up there seems to be a higher rate
than then some people think there should
be why is that is that connected to
partial fills still have to do more data
mining find out I wish I had that data
for you but I don't right now
so what's the next stage after this now
we're still trying to enter we're trying
to enter the experienced analytic stage
well the next stage is transformational
how can we advance knowledge can we
predict demand before it happens can we
predict it well enough that we can buy
less drugs ahead of time until we
absolutely know we're going to need to
and what about transitions of care
patients going home getting discharged
how can we use our data to contribute to
research in that this is these are
important areas with continuing care
scotsman repair possible readmissions we
need to be able to connect this
information
is there an optimum level of partial
fills and out of stocks if you never
have a partial fill you'll have a
bloated inventory we don't have
unlimited money we don't have unlimited
space to store thousands of products so
you have to try to limit your this is a
classic operations research question how
do you make a trade off between
maximizing patient satisfaction and
minimizing inventory costs can we reduce
inventory costs and increase patient
satisfaction at the same time by
predicting drug demand for discharge
patients so I would say this is a
classic operations research question
that I would love to be able to answer
but first we also have to make the
business case for whether it's worth
worth answering how much is it costing
us to not know these things
pharmacies dependent on multiple factors
so they one person I know is fond of
saying pharmacy is a dependent variable
um you know patients discharged from the
hospital they want to get their first
bills of a drug pharmacy is totally
dependent on a lot of factors how many
patients are getting discharged what are
their conditions the clinical units what
procedures what are their trends in one
of the trends in prescribing what
percentage of people choose to use the
pharmacy instead of going to walgreens
so if I were going to start looking into
this as a research problem I'd start
looking at you know what are what is the
volume of drugs dependent on VI here
should be Qi to match the Qi up their
quantity I wanted to say quarter sorry
about that so the quantity of drugs here
I'm proposing that it's a function of
the expected volume of discharges for a
given condition on a given day
the percent of patients with that
condition who are prescribed that drug
percent of patients who choose the
pharmacy as their pickup location the
very simplified version of what kind of
functional dependency might expect now
different components of this are already
in place ohsu has an expected discharge
number that they publish I don't know
how they get that number I've no idea
other people have done research into
this here's a example of a scoring
system to predict how many people are
going to be going home so you can
certainly use these kinds of models as
input into a demand model
you also have people working on
inventory allocation and this is a
classic operations research problem it's
in a lot of industrial engineering
literature it's mostly on the inpatient
side here this is just an example of you
know the blue is the current hospital
model it's not a HS you this is from a
research paper different hospital and
then some people use operational
research techniques modeling techniques
to come up with two different models
that show well you can actually reduce
your inventory significantly if you know
what factors to look for so ultimately I
think you know as far as outpatient
pharmacy goes these are the kinds of
transformational analytics that are
going to change the way the business
operates we still have a little ways to
go before we get there there are a lot
of questions vs how much do we pay for
the drugs how much do we get reimbursed
do we have too much or too little
inventory what are the costs associated
with low patient satisfaction when do
your patients turn away and go somewhere
else are we buying efficiently
patient satisfaction questions that need
to be asked how well can we deliver the
drug when the patient wants it or needs
it wire fills cancelled at a relatively
high rate do partial fills have
different refill capture rates you have
a first fill but you have a series of
refills after that if your patients not
happy and leaves you miss a whole stream
of refills down the road over the next
several months that's a lot of cost
that's a lot that's a lot of revenue
walking out the door what factors drive
patient satisfaction these are all kind
of some of these are connected and of
course quality questions does the
patient get the correct prescription
medication dispensing error questions so
I think these are all areas that we need
to we need to understand better in
pharmacy that I think that these are
areas that need to be understood better
that are opportunities for using
analytics to improve our business and
give a better patient experience at ohsu
so returning to this where is our
current capability for using analytics
I'm putting us somewhere around here
that's just my own personal opinion from
what I see
and how are we able to transform this
problem and use of analytics to achieve
all these things we talked a little bit
about you know designing metrics to suit
what you're trying to measure you know
the individual patients that are
involved trying to get their drugs the
integration of systems that allows data
to be put together efficiently and used
in a way that ultimately we can reduce
the per capita cost you know how can we
provide better quality healthcare at a
lower cost and I think systems
integration enables analytics and then
development of analytics ultimately
enables this goal
so thank you that's all I have any
questions
not yeah curious to what degree are your
interfaces dependent on the designs of
other systems because you know if epic
decides to change how their module
functions then that sort of dumps a bit
of a workload on you well we actually so
the IT group has a dedicated interfaces
team and they become our friends as a
matter of fact well you've seen how many
interfaces we have with the outside
world so what after our implementation
was finished our team took the
interfaces team and the printer and the
printer guy out for a beer because
without them you know we definitely
couldn't have done done this project
there's at least two different kinds of
interfaces that epic uses they have a
web services interface and I believe us
a more traditional TCP IP interface and
I I should really go and check on on
that because I don't want to give you
wrong information but there are 22
different main kinds i know one of them
is web services or phase and what do you
mean when they change I suppose I was
curious as to if you know they add new
functionality they may add you know a
new function call in their web interface
and that you'll have to either
incorporate that into your system or not
so the interface is that we use usually
come up with pre-built functionality we
don't get to do anything to the
interfaces we have to work with the
vendors to make sure that any upgrades
done on one side are compatible with the
other side so sometimes we have epic and
the vendors work together to make sure
that if they're changing one side is
changing their system
yep
yeah so could you talk a little bit
about the process and what it might take
to move some of this stuff into the data
warehouse that you're talking about and
therefore make it integrated with the
other data for asking questions and
analytics I can what does that look like
without telling any tales you know yeah
um so the data warehouse has a number of
data Mart's that are associated that
serve different departments at ohsu and
currently pharmacy does not have its own
data Mart all right so part of the
process of integrating this is the
process of creating a pharmacy data Mart
ultimately
there's an entire intelligence business
intelligence team that governs the data
warehouse and the extract and transform
and load system so we we can only take
it so far we can prototype how to do it
we are we're in the process of
prototyping a data Mart but we have to
do it with the cooperation of the
business intelligence team to understand
what their data model is so if we build
something it has to be ready to be moved
into the other system and this is a long
process so I don't know if that really
answers your question but involves
working with the business intelligence
team and divvying up responsibilities
between which team does what we can
prototype things up to a certain point
but after that point we have to
coordinate with them how to get it into
the enterprise system these etl steps
that you've already built I mean there's
some you know very particular data
capturing you know that's sort of
outside the itg scope at least initially
until you shove it in there are they
going to inherit that or they're going
to have to do it their own way or you
know how how do you envision this this
moving forward I think that this is
intelligence is asking the same
questions and we are too so we're not we
haven't we're in the beginning stages of
you know we have a data model and we've
just gotten approved for a database to
do prototyping and the next step is we
have to coordinate with with business
intelligence and talk to them about how
to do this it's really more their area
of expertise that ours so we don't want
to waste effort we don't want to do
things that get thrown away and we don't
want to do things that are at odds with
their design philosophy either so it
involves close coordination I don't know
the
technical details yeah of your question
that's an excellent question it's the
exact questions that we're asking right
now
thank you
you